[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this episode
we're breaking down the mirror world
theory on Westworld it's something
that's surrounded this season since its
first episode and every week that
becomes more and more evidence to
support it I've gone back and rewatched
the season from the beginning and
there's a ton of hints towards it being
the case that I definitely think are
worth going over throughout this video
we're going to be breaking them all down
and discussing whether these are flaws
that showcase what's really going on or
if it's all merely a coincidence there
will of course be heavy spoilers here so
if you haven't seen up to episode 7 of
season 3 yet then I highly recommend
that you turn off now
we haven't watched the finale yet as of
making this video so any speculation on
this is purely for fun but it will be
interesting to see if this happens when
the show concludes obviously we'd love
it if you subscribe to the channel and
with the finale right around the corner
there's never been a better time to join
if not then thank you for clicking the
video now let's get into our breakdown
of the mirror world theory okay so this
theory was first handed out in episode 1
by the lovable rogue Roderick at a party
to celebrate the Dempsey's he paid lip
service to the possibility that
everything could just be a simulation
within a simulation it's a theory that's
floated around since the show first
began and initially it seemed like the
writers were just poking fun at this
with this moment however in episode 2 we
followed Maeve who was actually trapped
within a simulation and by episode 3
things just went all out
not only did Dolores state that Ciroc
had created a mirror world to predict
human behavior but in episode 4 the
character also confirmed this the French
feature is said that Rehoboam contained
the most comprehensive picture of human
behavior ever seen and in its mirror
world it was able to predict future
events with almost certain accuracy
however he did stay that the word gaps
in the data and this is why he needed
the information within Dallas which
contained an even larger database this
has been the main thrust of his mission
but is it possible that everything we've
watched or at least certain elements of
it or within this mirror world well
personally I believe so and after
re-watching the season there's so many
mistakes and inconsistencies in it that
I think it's almost glaringly obvious
that syn elements are within the AI god
in episode 7 when caleb in dolores
encountered salomon it seemed to have
difficulty understanding whether this
was actually reality or if it was just a
simulation this clearly happened with
such accuracy that when going through it
for real it was unable to distinguish
whether it was actually happening or not
therefore we can gather that the
simulation itself appears extremely
realistic rather than just being a
collection of code the season has been
littered with moments that show
divergences and just in the same way
that we travel to past events through
the use of a Rehoboam graphic we could
also be seeing the mirror world through
it too now let's firstly go a bit meta
and look at the logo for Westworld
season 3 if you look at the W it's split
down the middle and appears as a
palindrome a mirror image of itself in
which it becomes exactly the same when
flipped one side is darker than the
other though perhaps showing that the
mirror world runs a darker version of
events and imagining of the worst-case
scenario so that Seurat can counter it
that's just the logo though and yeah I
will admit we could be completely
reading into that so let's look at the
show itself mirrors or at least the
suggestion of them are used throughout
it for example Dolores and Hale mirror
one another not only in their
personalities being split but also the
color schemes that are used for them
Dolores wears black halo wears white and
this splitting of their personalities
into could also suggest that people on
the whole have copies of themselves
there's also a statue behind them that
looks like it's tearing itself into hail
shaved William and his mansion which
reflected Dolores shaving him in the
park and through the season there has
been this suggestion now there has been
one aspect that we've seen in the series
that we know for definite was a
simulation and that is Maeve's trip
through war willed on the whole it was
very accurate except for a couple of
notable inconsistencies firstly Lutz and
Sylvester did not recognize Maeve they
had a massive journey together in the
park so them being unaware of who May
was was a big giveaway that something
was off
secondly was Lea Sizemore and this
actually the thing that made me realize
that everything was taking place within
a computer the system incorrectly
guessed that Lee was in love with Maeve
because of this it even went so far as
assigning him drawings that he created
of her showing that a mistake within the
machine can cause a butterfly effect
that spirals out into all aspects of the
person now in the show elements that
aren't taking part in a simulation also
possess these inconsistencies the first
major one that sort of set everyone off
tumbling down the rabbit hole came in
episode 3 in which hilarous listened to
messages left by the real Charlotte to
her son and played these and breakdowns
before but just in case you've missed
them I'll play them again in just a bit
listen close to the inconsistencies and
make your own mind up from this
at what time
[Music]
so clearly though they are similar in a
lot of ways there are some minor dialog
changes and moments that don't quite
line up with one another the way that
Hale sits when listening to them both is
also a mirror as she sits on opposite
sides to herself
one is listened to during the day and
the other one is at night once more
showing perhaps a reflection and yeah
this seems like such a big mistake that
it's difficult to argue that the
showrunners didn't put it in
intentionally what if her lure is
actually only listened to the message
once and one was the real-time and the
other was just a simulation that got key
aspects wrong well it definitely could
be Soraka late has stated that the real
Hale would never check in on a Sundering
a crisis and this message clearly points
to that not being the case showing that
the information that he got from a
Holborn was wrong this is really the
moment that made me go back and watch
the entire series before the finale
and I've noted down a lot more
inconsistencies since becoming aware of
this the first big one happens when
Caleb awakens and we are first
introduced to him he gets a call from
Francis and if you look at what he does
to his phone he clearly clearly clearly
presses decline however we cut
immediately to him taking a walk to work
and talking to the AI version of the
character on the phone so either he
declined the call and then answered
another one right after it or in the
real world he declined it and in the
mirror world he answered it another one
of note happens when Bernard is at the
farm that specializes in turning animals
from lab to slab he finds a calf with a
broken leg that has barbed wire wrapped
around it the camera lingers on this for
quite some time and it clearly draws
attention to it however after Bernard is
approached by another employee we cut
back to the cow to see that the barbed
wire is gone it was not removed and
perhaps Rehoboam could not determine the
cause of why the animal broke its leg so
it didn't end up putting it in but now
it heads back to his Shack and on the
way he passes a group about to break out
into a fight how about we later see that
they're standing around doing karaoke so
either they found the healing power of
music or something was wrong in the
mirror
these shots happened just seconds apart
so yes something definitely seems off
in the episode Liam introduces Dolores
his girlfriend to his friends at the
party and we later learn the identity
she took was Laura Aspen
however Roderick's girlfriend later
refers to her as Laura rather than Laura
another mistake with Caleb happens in
his history he calls the waitress that
came to him after his mother's
disappearance Sarah
even though according to her name badge
she's called Sora Connells is also
referred to as canals by several
characters and a God in Episode five
calls the system Rehoboam to sir axe
face I'm not even kidding this guy is
why I was calling it Rehoboam instead of
Rehoboam for so many episodes now these
are little mistakes that could just be
put down to people pronouncing things
incorrectly for example meaning Connells
who are from the UK called Ciroc Ciroc
whereas others call him Ciroc
so yes YouTube depending on what part of
the world you live in people pronounce
things differently Hale also committed a
fashion faux pas when she wore the same
dress twice in two different episodes
this could either be because she loves
that jacket or Rehoboam could have
wrongly assumed which day she was going
to wear it on when Bernard is journeying
back to the motel in episode 4 we see
some Rockets landing and these are
actually real-world ones known as V T V
Elle's which stands for vertical takeoff
and vertical landing the sky run them
looks murky and very hazy however when
we see things from Bernards perspective
later it's blue there are also some
minor ones such as us believing that
Bernard and Stubbs had gone to the
re-education Center in Mexico when
really they gone to San Francisco
Salomon is sort of a mirror image of
Rehoboam and even the giant AI balls are
in some ways larger versions of the
pills that are the brains of the hosts
in addition to this we did see a strange
choice in Maeve's allies initially it
was thought that she may choose
armistice but instead she opted for the
version from Shogun world now why this
is important it's because they didn't
really have a connection and still for
whatever reason she chose her over
someone that's been with her from the
start it seemed a bit strange when
looking at it like this and though it is
relatively close to what may would have
chosen it also perhaps shows that the
machine does not get everything right
but what's the point no less well
there's a couple of theories floating
about it could be possible that Dolores
is actually broken into the mirror world
to see what would happen she may be here
to rescue Caleb as the character
potentially died in the real one after
committing suicide and she's broken into
it to make him cause an uprising that
will crash the system we've seen that if
enough chaos is caused that things can
shut down and perhaps this is actually
the way to destroy Rehoboam mirroring
this the mirror world itself could be
created by serac so that he can run
through a simulation in which he uses
mave to fight Dolores and he's merely
testing the outcome either way I do
think that there was an explanation for
all these mistakes and that is that the
showrunners are just really crappy and
have no idea what they're doing now I'm
just kidding I think that Dolores is a
host and therefore there was no data
collected on her
therefore Rehoboam is unable to predict
her behavior so more and more
divergences are created making the
system spiral out of control and meaning
that it gets more and more things wrong
Dolores is looking for a way to free all
people from the system and there she's
made them a messiah who just so happened
to also be an outlier which we also know
are people that Rehoboam isn't able to
predict
therefore as serac cannot see the future
he cannot defend against it and she can
finally free her kind and bring humanity
crashing down and that's the video the
good thing about this one is right that
even if it doesn't get announced in the
finale I can just keep peddling this
theory until the show finally ends and
be like well it could be happening so
I've got you there now obviously I loved
hear your thoughts on this theory so
comment below and let me know if you
enjoyed this video then make sure you
check out a breakdown of the other big
fan theories before the finale which is
gonna be linked at the end every month
in the 15th we give away free blu-rays
and all you have to do to be in one the
chance of winning the marble face repot
one box set is leave a like and
subscribe with notifications on if you
want to support the channel and get to
see content early then please consider
clicking the join button you can also
come chat to us on our discord server
link below or a definition whitey on
twitter those are the best ways to keep
up to date with the channel so hopefully
we see over there very soon this is the
channel for people who are never missing
television so if that's the kind of
thing you like you need to subscribe to
definition thanks again for taking the
time to watch this you've been the best
and I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]